you're watching white coming up on this
week's show we meet Apple co-founder
Steve Wozniak and the young
entrepreneurs hoping to follow in his
footsteps
meanwhile I sit down with a scientist
touted as doing for health what Apple
did for computers and we've got a game
you will enjoy
well our reviewer says you will anyway
welcome to swipe from business rocks in
Manchester a tech summit with startups
pitching their ideas surrounded by
influential names the organizers here
say they want it to be technology's
answer to the Glastonbury Festival well
if it was it'd certainly have a good
headline act Steve Wozniak the Apple
co-founder is here and our technology
correspondent Tom Cheshire has been
speaking to him Apple has resisted the
fbi's called to build software get info
but it's also resisted calls to unlock
phones it does have access to where do
you draw the line between protecting
people's privacy but also protecting
citizens and helping the government
that's been elected to protect them
Apple stood about all it can Apple
doesn't have a switch they can turn on
and release the data was recently
released at something like three to five
thousand cases
Apple turned over data when they can get
data that way to rewrite the software
that makes a phone a good product and
keeps its data secure you know what the
police are interested in communications
anyway trying to track down who's
talking to whom and what are they saying
that's all done in the communications
companies and the FBI already has all
its backdoors in to Verizon and AT&T and
they've got every single bit of that
anyway so encryption just to protect my
data my my personal codes my finances my
my photographs and things that are
important to me in the phone Apple Apple
promise and that's a good thing to do
what if the FBI could come into any
company and say we now have to force you
you have to make your product insecure
for us why would you build a product
that's insecure that's doing a very bad
thing in computer terms we've had a lot
in the papers about taxes recently there
are a lot of people who are angry that
corporations including Apple don't
pay that much tax do you think Apple
pays enough tax so I feel very sorry for
people to have psychological problems
and have to get angry about something
it's always existed that we've always
known that that wealthy parties and
companies have all these offshore places
to hide money it's always existed no no
it's not it's not right and we should
say that it's wrong and but why should
we get upset about a new recent one
every one that comes up I mean we are
the ones who are basically we're in a
democracy we voters have control over
our Congress people who write the laws
that make it possible or not I mean just
because it's the case doesn't mean that
it's right and should Apple pay more tax
just financial people and their
motivations are only to find the last
little penny that they can get by any
trickery to read legal documents and
find escapes and loopholes and search
for friendly governments basically to do
what a wealthy person does to try to
hide their their wealth and disguise it
and get it out of the tack away from
taxes yes same thing but they're paid to
do that and you can't blame because
every single company in the world would
do it and Apple isn't run by a few
ethical people it's run by a millions of
shareholders you might have some apples
talking you're the one who wants them to
make the profit there's no shortage of
people hoping to follow in Steve's
footsteps Angela's been looking at his
influence on some of the young
entrepreneurs here today this is 15 year
old Brandon Ralph he started a company
which stemmed from his love of gaming
and he's already achieved his goal of
making ten thousand pounds from it
before his 16th birthday we own a
minecraft design team where we basically
get commissioned by companies to build
stuff in Minecraft for those of you that
don't know Minecraft is like virtual
Lego and our work is used in marketing
and for charity working in education
brandon spends a few hours a night on
his business in between doing his
homework Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak
started his business in a garage alone
side it's friend Steve Jobs building
what went on to become the world's most
iconic computer brand Brandon hopes to
follow in his footsteps looking for
inspiration and for someone to further
invest in their ideas
seventeen-year-old Ben towers is another
young success story he started a digital
media agency when he was just 11 as a
company with our turnover been hoping to
aim at 600,000 this year and still may
exceed it you know it's quite an
exciting opportunity we're getting doing
a lot of stuff trying to make the
company prote what we do because you
tend to work a challenger brands so
companies here obviously want to compete
and want new ideas and want innovative
ways of working so it's really helping
us as a company to move forward as well
the Apple success story belongs to the
two Steve's but these young
entrepreneurs are writing their own
Angela burns of Sky News
now before I sit down with one of the
world's leading nanotechnology experts
here's a roundup of some of this week's
other tech news this week seen a greener
way to charge your device's launched on
IndieGoGo it's exactly what it looks
like a plant but this one's got a clever
pop that uses energy in the soil
produced by photosynthesis to generate
electricity the makers of by who say the
plant is not harmed in any way gearing
up for exam season and education tech
startups hoping you'll ops for a bit of
help from what it's nicknamed the uber
for tutors spires has teachers from
Oxford and Cambridge on its database and
says it wants to provide affordable
tutoring for students one company's on a
mission to revolutionize the surfboard
industry Moss Research has launched a
funding campaign on Kickstarter to back
its boards made of recycled and
plant-based materials and a team of
three University students have launched
an online donation platform trying to
help non-mainstream charities raise
funds but give a three is a little
different because it uses gamification
techniques to do it the aim is to make
raising money more fun
coming up in this week's games review
the title proving big in Japan Steve
Wozniak might be the most famous name
here today but there are plenty of other
influential figures from the worlds of
science and technology I've been lucky
enough to sit down with one breakthrough
inventor who's even been advising the
Obama administration on nanotechnology
no less now dr. aneta when I was
researching I found so many ways of
describing you humanitarian global
entrepreneur well renowned biophysics
extroverts how do you like to be well
you know I'm a physicist and medical
doctor my dream
I love nanotechnology as a we
that is such a Kevin that makes
technology bring the study of tiny tiny
things tell us on that I said no
technology is really a science
associated with learning kind of control
and study nature on very very small
scales 10 to the minus 9 meters as fixed
on your lap here has been described as a
real game-changer you and your company
have developed this tell us how it works
it's called cheerleader and what it is
is a way to diagnose disease with a
genetic signature a DNA or RNA
fingerprint in real time with gold
standard accuracy at a very affordable
so what we're doing is we're creating
apps for each key disease that were
looking after and each app is one
disease content
we have a disposable chip a reader and
an app and that basically helps you
diagnose diseases like people
hmm do you want is to be in GP surgeries
or hospitals while our initial thing is
to partner with hospitals and doctors
and clinics and put it into those places
but eventually we see it as a consumer
device that you would have
villages and development
and you've been advising President
Obama's administration on the nanos
and future health
what is it that we've my need to worry
about I've served on a number of
nanotechnology boards that advice
administration and what I believe that
nanotechnology represents it's supposed
to be a four point eight trillion dollar
industry in the next five years but it's
mostly sitting in academic class in
order to change the wheel that's not
enough for me to create the technologies
in our lab we have to kind of go out
planet Earth to get the entire human
experience get people engaged with these
technologies so they can figure out help
us figure out time for this week's video
games review now is correct
so Ratchet and Clank is a reboot of a
PlayStation 2 PlayStation 3 era game and
it's also gonna be a film which is
coming out so this games got quite a lot
going on pushed right into it not only
is it got the expectations of people who
love the old series it's got all the
people that are making the new film
being like please make the game good and
is that's the fun part of it it's really
good it's a really lovely friendly sort
of Technicolor joyful game incoming drop
ship dejected you will enjoy this and
some people have said the story's a bit
simplistic but it's the characters that
you're here for and the characters are
really fun speaks well to the film being
really fun as well in the future but who
knows for now though ratcheting climb is
a lot of fun ok watch is a game that's
been taking Japan by storm quite a while
now it's a game on the 3ds to handheld
game and people have compared it a lot
to Pokemon but really kind of the main
comparison is just how huge this thing
has got in Japan the main thing about
this game you go around you've got your
yokai watch so the watch finds the yokai
you find them you solve whatever their
problem is and then they can become your
friend who can help you out to find
other yokai and help them out
if you're an adult it's not the most
challenging game in the world you can
kind of just sit there and let it do its
own thing but it's the world that kind
of kept me there it's a really nice
relaxing world so if you're in your
commute in the morning it's nice to just
sit there and just be like relax and
ride around your little bike and look
around and talk to little spirits and
stuff
stocks do you read me Star Fox series
was something that completely wild
people back on the Super Nintendo it was
a ton of fun on the Nintendo 64 and it
kind of wasn't so good on the Gamecube
because rather than being more
traditional game when you flew it around
in a spaceship and shot stuff and hung
out with your friends in space you saw
the 3d platformer II thing with talking
dinosaurs in a made-up language nobody
wanted that it's really fun if you spent
your childhood sat cross-legged in front
of a star fox game or a lilac Wars or
whatever they call them back then you'll
love this it has exactly the same feel
so you can sit on the sofa now because
you probably get pins and needles in
your legs I know I do but it's a ton of
fun you'll enjoy it
well that's it from us here at business
rocks time we went back to London take a
look at Sky News on mobile tablet
catch-up and sky queue for all the
latest tech stories throughout the week
and you can see that steve wozniak
interview in full I'll see you again
next time
bye bye